last month apple did something they've
never done before
they released two brand new apple watch
models
the series six and the budget-oriented
se model
this review is going to be focused on
the apple watch se
in my experience and thoughts on it
after having it here in the office
for two weeks but instead of this being
the same old review you see on every
other channel
i want to mix things up and take a
unique look at the apple watch sc
from apple's perspective in terms of
their marketing
master plan and why they decided
to release this model alongside the
series 6.
if you're in apple shoes your ultimate
goal is to sell as many
apple watches as possible and the best
way to do that
is try to make a trend that catches on
that's why the overall design of the
apple watch
hasn't really changed in the last 6
years ever since tim cook
said one more thing and introduced the
very first apple watch
at their september event in 2014.
apple's ultimate goal was to make the
apple watch
a symbol of their brand just like they
did with the original airpods
which basically went viral and that's
why the design
hasn't really changed on the apple watch
and apple
succeeded with the apple watch becoming
not only the best selling smart watch in
the world
but also the best selling watch
period in the world you can basically
see people wearing apple watches
everywhere and while that's great for
apple it does create a problem
when most people buy an apple watch they
keep it for years
most likely at least three four or maybe
even five years
we made a few apple watch videos last
week and i was surprised by the amount
of people who said
they still have their original apple
watch or even the series 2.
so the problem that this creates for
apple is market saturation
this basically means that no matter how
good your brand new apple watch is
if everyone already owns one there's no
one left
to sell it to sales will ultimately go
down
unless you can figure out a way to
either get people to upgrade to a new
one
or find a completely new market of
people
who are willing to buy one and i'm here
to tell you
that apple has figured it out but before
i tell you how
let's get into the second major issue
for apple
and that's feature saturation when apple
released their series 5 watch last year
they immediately discontinued the series
4.
they did that because it was almost the
same exact watch
in fact there were only three changes
the always-on display 32 gigs of storage
instead of 16 and the compass feature
that's it and even last month they
revealed the series 6
while immediately discontinuing the
series 5
for the exact same reason this time
there are only
6 changes the red and blue finishes
the always on altimeter the blood oxygen
sensor
the brighter always on display while in
direct sunlight
the faster processor and the ultra
wideband chip
now while there are more changes than
before a lot of those things don't
really matter to someone who already has
the series 5
and that's why my brother max is
returning the apple watch series 6.
that's also why i'm not buying it for my
wife
she already has the series 4 and she
says she's completely happy with it and
it does everything she wants it to do
that's called feature saturation when
your apple watch
is so feature-rich already that it's
very hard to think of groundbreaking new
features
that'll make people want to upgrade to
the latest model so from apple's point
of view
this is a problem especially if they
want to continue selling apple watches
for the next 5 to 10 years which their
investors
are counting on so i'm here to tell you
that apple has figured it out
and it all starts with the name the
apple watch sc
back in april of this year apple
released the brand new iphone se
and they had three main goals for that
iphone at least in my opinion
goal number one was to make it
affordable for other countries like
china and
india where the bulk of the smartphone
market share
goes to lower priced phones and at 399
dollars for an iphone
with the latest chip it's definitely a
great value
goal number two was to get people who
were still using older iphones
like the iphone 5 the iphone 6 and the
iphone 7
to upgrade 400 bucks for a brand new
iphone with the latest chip
a brand new battery and a familiar
design
is definitely enough to get non-techie
users to upgrade
and it even attracted a bunch of android
users as well
which brings us into goal number three
make an affordable smartphone that's a
great choice for parents
to buy for their kids mainly young
teenagers
399 dollars is very reasonable for an
iphone
but here's the secret that most people
don't think about
if you're a teen and the first phone you
own is an iphone
you're much more likely to upgrade to
another iphone in the future
since you've now become comfortable with
the operating system
and there you go apple has another
lifetime apple customer
that's much more likely to buy apple
devices and pay
for apple services and that finally
brings us to
the apple watch se it's basically got
almost all the same features as the
series 6
but it's only 279 dollars
so this is what can finally get those
people
who still own an older apple watch to
upgrade
but that's not even the biggest deal out
of
all of the new features apple released
this year for the apple watch
the absolute most important feature is
the new family setup feature now you can
set up an apple watch for someone who
doesn't have an iphone
this means someone with an android phone
can now use an apple watch
an elderly person with health issues can
now use an apple watch without an
iphone and most importantly a child
can now have an apple watch without an
iphone
now if you think that's crazy it
actually makes a whole lot of sense
compared to buying a smartphone for your
child compared to even the cheapest
iphone
the iphone sc for 399 you can get the
apple watch sc
with lte for 329
which is the model you want for family
setup on top of that
cellular service for wearables is
significantly cheaper
than getting another smartphone line for
example
t-mobile charges 28 dollars per line
for the absolute cheapest plan and
that's if you have a total of four lines
but to add a wearables device it's
literally only
ten dollars a month per device so you're
saving money
on every front by going with an apple
watch
instead of an iphone so for a child
ranging from ages 8
to around 13 or maybe even 15 an
apple watch makes sense because you
don't have to worry about them dropping
and cracking their iphone
or even worse losing it it's always on
their wrist so you can track their
location at any time
you can text them or call them no matter
where they are
and you don't have to worry about them
browsing the web on sites they shouldn't
be looking at
or maybe even worse using tick tock you
can manage who they're able to
communicate with
and you can even send cash directly to
their apple watch
which they can spend at any place that
supports apple pay
it's basically the perfect solution for
keeping in touch with children that
aren't
old enough or responsible enough to have
their own smartphone
and i personally think that buying apple
watches for kids
is gonna become a trend within one to
two years
if you think about it when everything
goes back to normal and kids start going
back to class
every single kid in the classroom will
notice the apple watch
on that one kid's wrist and that kid is
gonna show off his new memoji watch face
that looks exactly like him and just
like what happened with the airpods
every single kid in the classroom is
gonna want
an apple watch and there is one thing i
know for sure
that child apple watch user is almost
guaranteed to become an apple watch user
in the future
which means they're also likely to
become an iphone user as well
so to wrap all of this up if you're in
apple's shoes
and the apple watch has just about
reached peak levels of market saturation
and feature saturation what do you do
you spark a new trend of apple watches
for kids
and you secure the future generation of
users who will eventually be much more
likely
to buy apple products and services when
they grow up
and that is apple's master plan
for the apple watch sc and here's a
little bit of proof that apple is quite
literally planning this
why do you think they release the solo
loot bands that you simply stretch onto
your wrist
because it's meant to be easier for kids
as well as the elderly oh and by the way
i forgot to share my experience with the
apple watch sc
it's basically been great and if you
don't care about the always on display
or the added health features just buy
the se
especially if you want to get an lte
model since you'll save 170 bucks
compared to the series 6. and there you
guys have it
hopefully you enjoyed my marketing focus
review of the apple watch se
and if you did go ahead and click the
circle to subscribe for more videos like
this one
and consider checking out our apple
product merch like this t-shirt
right over there and watch that video
whatever it is
up there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next one